starcraft 2 is a multiplayer game where
the objective is simply to eliminate the
other players you do so with an army of
attack units we like this we do not like
this those attack units cost resources
to make so you probably need to set up a
base build various buildings collect
resources and then you can build that
army all of this involves seemingly
endless strategizing and knowledge of
the game along with years of tuning
muscle memory to achieve high actions
per minute but we're programmers and we
can just use libraries that let us use
python code to play the game for us even
this however takes a while to master all
of the strategies but we're also machine
learning practitioners could we just
simply import some reinforcement
learning from stable based lines 3 and
play the game i guess it's going to be a
little harder than that but let's say
that we really do want to use deep
reinforcement learning to play some
starcraft 2. how might we actually do
that like most deep learning problems at
the macro level we have to consider what
our inputs and what our outputs are
going to be as these are the things that
we actually have control of and we have
to determine the characteristics of
these ahead of time for the input what
information do we think the neural
network will actually need in this case
it could quite literally be the game
visuals like the frames from the game it
could be some other graphical
representation or it could just be a
vector of values like number of units
and minerals and locations of things and
so on then for the output of this model
we need to consider what this neural
network can actually decide essentially
with deep reinforcement learning in this
case this is going to be the actions
that the model can actually take like
whether to expand and build out our base
to attack the enemy and so on for the
input into the model i think something
like the minimap is actually a really
good candidate for model input showing
the actual game would mean that the
agent would have to come up with some
logic to either move the camera around
or it would probably wind up mostly
paying attention to the mini-map anyways
so i think building our own version of
the mini-map with the data that we think
is important i think that's the best
place to start from for the input map
we're going to start with a blank canvas
that is just simply the size of the game
map then first we're going to draw the
minerals not only are we going to draw
them but we'll also make them more
bright the more minerals there are left
we'll use the same concept for minerals
as well as the gas but also a similar
idea for building and unit health here's
the result of this so far we can only
gather information on minerals that we
can see with units which is why some of
them are just very dim and then some are
very bright the dim ones we just we
haven't seen so we have no idea how many
minerals are there next we'll mark the
enemy starting location with a red dot
then we're going to use a similar
strategy for enemy units in another red
and then enemy structures as well in a
red color then we're going to mark our
own nexus buildings in a light blue
color and then all the other structures
a greenish color we're going to mark
vespine as a pink we're doing this after
our structures because if we just slap a
structure on top of the vespine we
wouldn't actually know what the amount
of spin was right you can only have one
thing on a square so i just went with
draw the buildings first because we end
up building a building on top of the gas
to collect the gas so draw the buildings
first then draw the best bean then
finally we'll draw all our units which
will be green by default but we're going
to color the void ray unit which is our
attack unit specifically a blue i think
this gives us a pretty good final result
where it's fairly easy to see what's
going on in the game i did most of my r
d here in linux which didn't allow me to
run the graphical representation of the
game and just by watching games with
this representation i think it's really
easy to see what's going on how we're
doing and all that i think you could
definitely make good decisions with this
information so i think this will be a
pretty good starting point for input to
our model will it work maybe remember
the best thing that we can do is keep
things simple to start one issue i can
already imagine here is that this is
just a ton of mostly noise per input the
image is mostly empty so it's going to
be an area that we could probably
improve upon later but now that we have
network input we need to handle for the
output logic which will be the macro
actions that we're going to allow the
reinforcement learning agent to take for
action 0 i'm referring to it as the
expand action this is the code for it
essentially for expands we want to make
sure we have enough supply to grow and
build as many void rays as desired if we
have that then we'll check to make sure
we have enough probes these are
essentially the worker units if not
build more of those if we don't need
those then let's build assimilators to
collect the vespine gas finally if we
have all of this stuff then let's make
another base in another resource area
for action 1 it's all about building
stargates and to build stargates we need
gateways and cybernetics cores to also
exist if those don't exist build them
otherwise build a stargate right now the
code is limiting one stargate per base
but this could be changed to allow the
ai to make endless stargates
theoretically speeding up the ability
for you to build void rays faster for
action number two if we can afford and
we can build a void ray build one action
number three this is to scout just not
too often essentially scouting is
sending a poor probe to its certain
death and we're just doing this to see
what the enemy is up to
initially we're going to start out
completely random so theoretically one
out of every six frames we could be
sending a probe and this would be faster
than we could possibly build probes so
just to limit this we're adding a once
every 200 frames that's when you can
send another scout action four is to
attack first we're going to look for any
close units then any close buildings
than any known unit then any known
building per void ray
if all else fails then we're going to
send the void rays to the enemy start
location
we could probably get a little more
fancy here since it's totally possible
that we eradicate the enemy from its
starting location and we have no idea
where it is from this point but it's
somewhere building its base and
collecting resources and all that so we
might want to have some sort of ability
to hunt or seek out the enemy in other
locations finally action 5 is mostly
tuck tail and flea the void rays should
also be capable of
just simply returning to the base after
a fight so it's not just to flee it's
also just to bring our void rays back
home the void ray units are really our
only base defense here so if they're not
busy elsewhere we should bring them back
sometimes
at this point the last thing that we
need to do is calculate a reward for the
agent to learn from
but first is this even a worthy
experiment at all i can already hear
some people complaining that the agent
isn't controlling every single action in
the game and we must ask ourselves how
will we know if this agent is good or
not we need a benchmark to compare to so
before we waste our time on a reward
mechanism and all the r d required there
which honestly is often the hardest part
of any reinforcement learning
development we really do need to test
random which is really just a question
of how good does an agent do if it is
just randomly picking actions we have a
lot of helper code here some failsafes
isn't it really just possible that
randomly picking actions will also win
games or at least be remotely comparable
to any reinforcement learning agent well
we can test this really easily after
running 200 games running random actions
we have not won a single game
okay i think we have something we can
certainly work for all right now let's
talk reward
in order for the agent to learn anything
at all we need to reward it for doing
quote unquote good
rewarding agents and reinforcement
learning is often the hardest part of
all take our problem for example the
actual goal here is to win games it's
pretty simple if we win we could give
the agent a reward and if we lose a big
negative reward
the issue is as we've seen already the
agent starts off basically random and
the number of observations and actions
per game can be five thousand to ten
thousand or even more sometimes
if we go through 10 000 actions and lose
the game as we pretty much know we
initially will every single time how
will the agent know which actions were
the ones that lost the game and more
importantly which actions would be good
to take with this many actions to sift
through before getting an actual reward
it's far too challenging for a model to
discern which one was the good action
and which ones were the bad actions so
instead we're going to need some sort of
intermediary rewards to help boost the
activity that we think will be useful
for victory to do this you can just give
a very small reward per step for things
that you think might be helpful and then
you can still give one large reward at
the end for actually winning the game so
what might we reward to help win we
could reward resource gathering but this
would probably just result in an agent
prioritizing lengthening the game so it
can collect as many resources as
possible and it probably wouldn't want
to build many attack units since these
cost resources we could go off of total
units and buildings as well as a sort of
reward for the overall size of our
military but again this would
disincentivize the agent from actually
winning and completing the game instead
it would just want to build lots and
stay alive for as long as possible so
for me i personally settled on something
extremely simple a reward for attacking
for every void ray which is our
attacking unit that we have in our army
if that unit is actively in combat then
they earn the agent a small reward per
step this incentivizes actually
eliminating or at least attacking the
enemy it will still possibly be the case
that keeping the enemy just barely alive
to make more units and buildings for us
to destroy will happen but my hope is
that a large reward for actually
finishing the game will overcome this
okay so we've got some great ideas here
but we still have to actually connect
stable bass lines 3 in this python
starcraft 2 environment and to do that
we also need to convert the python sc2
environment to an open ai gem
environment in order to work with stable
baselines 3. due to the way everything
runs and can or cannot communicate while
it runs this presented a far more
difficult challenge than i expected if
you're looking to learn more about
stable bass lines 3 and custom
environments i'll put a link in the
description for a tutorial series i did
it's a lot more simple and easier to
understand if you're new to it compared
to what i'm going to be doing here so
for everything to communicate here i
ended up going with a state file this
file contains the state which is going
to be our minimap the reward action and
whether or not the game is done and this
shared file is how we'll communicate
between the systems here is there a
better way absolutely will this work
though i hope so so this is definitely
going to be very confusing with
everything that has to connect and wait
on each other and all this but let's
just go in logical order so to actually
run everything we're just going to have
a training script train dot pi and this
is what's going to actually run and
start up basically everything so for
train.pi there's really nothing fancy
here it's a typical stable baselines 3
training script the script runs the sc2n
file which i haven't shown yet for our
custom environment so now let's peek at
this sc2mv file so what this is is a
custom openai gym environment
essentially we have an init step in a
reset method again to learn more about
this check out the sp3 tutorial in the
description it'll be a much more easy to
understand than this but basically all
this does is initialize the action and
observation space for the agent
immediately
then before the environment actually
runs it is reset and here is where the
magic or hacky code happens in the reset
method we empty the map and prepare our
state pickle file note that the action
in this pickled dictionary is none to
start after creating and saving that
pickle we open up another process to
actually run the starcraft 2 game so
this is actually running the game with
the logic that we've kind of described
up into this point as well as through
the blizzard api and actually playing
starcraft 2. finally the reset method
actually is just returning an
observation which is that map that blink
map that we've created so at this point
theoretically the starcraft 2 game is
just kind of hanging out waiting for us
to issue commands to it so we've
returned this observation from the reset
method which stable base lines 3 via
this train dot pi file passes through
the reinforcement learning model in this
case that's a ppo model
and that model returns an action stable
baselines 3 then passes that action back
to our environment's step method in the
sc2m step method the first thing we wait
for is an action to be picked by the
model once we have that action we add it
to the state dictionary
keep in mind again up to this point the
action has been none
so what's actually waiting for an action
our actual starcraft 2 game and the
script that communicates with it which
is incredibot.pi once that script
detects a new action it performs the
action actually in the game it redraws
that map that we've created it
calculates any reward then replaces the
previous state dictionary with a new one
where yet again the action is none but
we're returning the reward and a new
observation we'll also handle at the end
for if the game actually ends
from here which script is waiting on an
action
that's the sc2 end script and the cycle
goes on until the game ends which will
issue a done and then the environment
resets and we continue on indefinitely
so yeah this is definitely the most
spaghetified code for reinforcement
learning that i've written but does it
work
of course it works around this time i
spent quite a while tinkering with
various rewards in logic but the one
that worked best was just a simple
reward for attacking and of course
winning or losing while the models were
training i was obviously tracking things
like overall reward the reward mechanism
itself changed quite a few times so each
variant isn't necessarily directly
comparable to the other one as well as i
have personally found that it's best to
try multiple times with the same exact
reinforcement learning algorithm as it
seems the random initialization starting
point of all models can actually play
quite a significant role with
reinforcement learning and that actual
model learning over time as you can
probably tell i made many attempts
before settling on that very simple
reward mechanism of just simply
rewarding for combat and then at the end
a reward or punishment for a winner loss
the best model landed on a reward of
about 200 at its peak that said what
does that actually translate to as
models trained i also kept a log of wins
and losses since that's actually what
we're truly after so i wanted to measure
the winning rate in the case of this
model at the same time as its 200 reward
peak we can see game victories at around
70
against the hard computer bot which
isn't too bad especially considering
random was literally zero percent we
were never winning despite the amount of
effort put in so far i would still
consider this just the beginning of any
reinforcement learning with starcraft 2
and i'll have to think more on how i
might expand this to do better at both
macro tasks like we've done here as well
as some sort of micro reinforcement
learning algorithm probably in the form
of two separate algorithms running at
the same time where one algorithm is
focusing on macro like what we have here
and making large overarching decisions
like build buildings and expand or
attack and so on and then another one
that focuses solely on micro tasks for
example like what coordinates to go to
or build on and so on but overall i'd
say this is a pretty good start i did
also attempt to build some sort of
hunting capability for the void rays to
find enemies at more locations than just
their base or if they just happen to
show up since it seemed like many games
were lost because the enemy just hid
when we had the advantage but later came
with a bigger army and defeated us i
ended up allowing void rays to look at
random coordinates if no other enemies
were present but my results here were
actually worse than when we weren't
looking at all i still think there's
something here to be fixed logically
probably fairly simply but again i
wonder about maybe instead making a
reinforcement learning algorithm that
chooses what coordinates to fly to
rather than me hand coding even more
logic i think making a micro strategy
reinforcement learning algorithm to pick
coordinates for travel is very likely
the next step to try that however is a
project for another day i've hosted all
the code as well as a decent model that
you can play with if you'd like you can
find that in the description of this
video if you're interested in learning
more about neural networks and how they
work then you might want to check out
neural networks from scratch a book by
myself and daniel kukiewa inside of
which you'll learn how to code neurons
activation functions how to calculate
loss to optimization and back
propagation and of course apply
everything that you've just learned to a
problem the book itself is in full color
for graphs and code syntax highlighting
everything's on high quality pages with
full font and a comfortable line spacing
to make reading easy finally every
concept including the math and coding is
broken down into the truly atomic parts
and then put back together step by step
to give a full understanding of neural
networks and how they work including all
the math behind them by the end of the
book you will have created your own
neural network framework from scratch
this is the book that i wish existed
when i was learning deep learning and
i'm extremely happy to be able to offer
it to you if this sounds interesting to
you then you can head over to nnfs
to learn more and buy yourself a copy
you